we're asked to solve for X and we have
this radical equation 1 is equal to the
principal root or the positive square
root of x divided by 3 minus 2 and the
best way to solve these is to just
isolate the radical and then square both
sides and then hopefully we'll be able
to solve for X this is a pretty
straightforward remit in general once
you solve for y or X sometimes you get
more than one solution and then you
always want to substitute them back in
to make sure that they all work and and
in other videos I've actually explained
why sometimes you end up with a solution
that does not work but let's just do
this it should be pretty straightforward
so the first thing to do if we want to
get rid of this negative 2 we could add
2 to both sides of this equation let's
add 2 to both sides of this equation the
left-hand side becomes 1 plus 2 is 3 is
equal to this negative 2 and positive 2
cancel out so we have the square root of
x over 3 then we can multiply both sides
of this equation by 3 let's multiply
both sides by 3 and so we get 9 9 is
equal to the square root of x 9 is equal
to the square root of x and then we can
just take the weekend to square both
sides of this equation we can square
both sides of this equation and if you
square both sides of this equation you
get 81 is equal to X now we only got one
solution here let's just try it out
let's see if it let's make sure that it
works for this equation so let's just
evaluate the right-hand side with X is
equal to 81 and make sure it equals 1 so
if we take the square root of 81 that's
our x over 3 this is our 81 right there
- to what is this square root of 81
we're taking the principal root the
positive square root so we're only going
to think about the positive square root
which is 9 9 over 3 minus 2 9 over 3 is
clearly 3 3 minus 2 is indeed equal to 1
so this is indeed x equals 81 is indeed
the solution for this radical equation